تنوع الطرق على احتجاجات في ايران
والتعبير عن الثقه في البلاد من تظاهرات
الى اعتصامات مرورا بالاضرابات وكتابه
الشعارات على جدران على مؤسسات النظام
وصولا الى احتجاج الطلبه في المدارس
والجامعه ومؤخرا مطالبات جماعيه للاستقاله
من البرلمان الايراني للتضامن مع
المحتاجين ومناهضه القمع وقتلهم من قبل
الاجهزه الامنيه الايرانيه ودعت مجموعه من
الكتاب في محافظه كردستان غرب البلاد في
بيان الى استقاله جماعيه للبرلمانيين
التضامنا مع الشعب الحزينه وفقا ما وصفه
البيان واعلن المواقعون على البيان دعمهم
للمطالب الشرعيه للمواطنين الايرانيين
المتجسده في الحريه والعداله والسلام
واذان قتل الناس في اي مكان
[تصفيق]
وبينما تتنوع وطرق الاحتجاج ينوع النظام
الايراني مشاهدينا هو الاخر من طرق قمعه
للمظاهرات سواء بقنسهم او خطفهم وتغيبهم
ومحاكمتهم ميدانيه حيله النظام الايراني
هذه المره كانت استخدام سيارات الاسعاف
لاعتقالي وخطف المحتاجين بعد التسلل الى
داخل الاحتجاجات واختراقها على اساس انها
طاقم طبي وفقا لنيويورك تايمز ويتبع عناصر
الامن اسلوبا تمويها عبر ارتداء زي
الممرضين والاطباء المسعفين ثم الدخول بين
المحتاجين على اساس انهم مؤيدين للتظاهرات
ومتطوعين لمساعده جرح الاحتجاجات ويؤكد
شهود عيان للصحيفه الامريكيه ان وقت
الامنيه زجت ثلاثه متظاهرين في بدايه
الشهر الماضي الى الداخل سيارات الاسعاف
بالقوه بالرغم من ان المحتاجين الثلاثه لم
يكون مصابين ومن ثم تبين اختفائهم لتتحول
ايران الى سجن كبير مع تجاوز عدد
المعتقلين اكثر من
14,000 معتقل خلال الاحتجاجات المستمره
منذ مقتل مهسا اميني وفقا لارقام الامم
المتحده طبعا والتيتاكدت مقتل 40 طفلا في
تلك الاحتجاجات حتى الان
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده التي طالبت السلطات
الايرانيه بوقف حمله القمع هذه دعت ايضا
الى الكشف عن مصير المعتقلين خصوصا ممن
صدرت بحقهم احكام الاعدام مشدده على ضروره
التراجع عن هذه الاحكام
ما يقولوش ناوي
في ايران وقوات الباسيج استخدمت الرصاصه
الحي والمطاطيه ضد المتظاهرين بالاضافه
لوسائل قمع اخرى وفقا لتقارير موثقه تقدر
حصيله الوفيات باكثر من 300 شخص حتى
اللحظه بينهم 40 طفلا على الاقل وهذا امر
غير مقبول تلقينا تقارير تفيد بان الجرح
في المظاهرات يخشون الذهاب الى المستشفيات
حتى لا يتم اعتقالهم التوام الطبيه تحدثت
عن تدخلات من قبل قوات الامن اثناء علاجهم
للجرحى مما تم جمعه من تقاريرها هناك نحو
14,000 شخص معتقلين لدى السلطات بما فيهم
اطفال
المانيا هي الاخرى جددت تمديدها بالقمع
المميته للاحتجاجات في ايران وطالبت بوقف
الحملات المنهجه بحق المتظاهرين وقالت
الخارجيه الالمانيه ان ايران رفضت مرارا
دخول البعثه من مجلس حقوق الانسان ورصد
الانتهاكات وكشفت عن مشروع قرار امم
لتشكيل لجنه تحقيق مستقله توفق الانتهاكات
زهريا في الداخل ايضا ارتفعت نسبه مشاركه
الفنانين والرياضيين والمثقفين الايرانيين
المتضامنين مع الاحتجاجات في بلادهم حيث
نشر مجموعه من كتاب وفنانين واكاديميين ما
قال المشتركا يبدون فيه تعاطفهم مع
المحتاجين وهو امر زاد من غضب النظام
الايراني وفقا الفرنسيه
هذا حكومات نظامي
[موسيقى]